here's the first motion picture to offer
to the daring a look into the final
maddening space between life and death
to avoid fainting keep repeating Michael
and I I'll get to indulge in the
all-night orgy of sex and violence
corpse of the virgin astronaut but the
carpet get off you sticky nasty it's a
carpet farty we can't get a pastor to
work on the surprise of he's dead
he has to not the video Oh have we got
the video yes there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey you guys welcome to
episode 75 now if you read the
description below then you will already
know that this is another just me
episode sorry about that but there were
some not exactly complications with
Tom's dad but there were a few kind of
things that made him want to stay longer
now I just got an update like right
before I started recording this and
actually the like I said he had the
surgery a week ago and it actually went
quite well but the recovery process was
a little slower than they were expecting
and they had to keep him under sedation
for several days until they could see if
his heart was going to be able to work
on its own and stuff like that when they
took him off the ventilator and things
like that now for a while there was like
no change and they weren't really sure
and they thought initially that they
were going to have to put in a permanent
pacemaker but I'm recording this on
Sunday morning and I just got news from
Tom about ten minutes ago that actually
he's really that actually his dad has
really bounced back today and he really
seems like he's doing very well he's
awake he's talking and stuff like that
so now the doctors are thinking maybe
they won't have to put in the pacemaker
and that everything is probably going to
be okay
but the thing is that when Tom thought
that there were they were going to put
the pacemaker and stuff like that he
cancelled his previous flight and was
actually going to get a flight for
Monday the day before this episode goes
up but then he couldn't get that flight
now the only other cheap flight
available for this week is the Friday
after this episode comes out so we
actually got him that flight so he will
be back in Florida on January 26th which
means that this should be the last
regular episode without Tom I probably
will have to do another movie review
without him and I'm telling you right
now it will probably be Suspiria because
that's what I wanted to do for a while
and I just
recently re-watched it and it's a movie
that Tom hasn't really seen so I will
probably do that one and that one will
also be me alone but after that then he
should be back he he basically told me
he's like I'm coming back on the 26th
regardless you know he's been gone he'll
he'll have been gone for two weeks by
then which you know it's a long time so
I still miss him but I'm glad his dad is
doing much better and hopefully we'll be
on well on the road to recovery by the
time Tom comes back and again thank you
very much everybody that commented on
the YouTube video and sent me messages
on Facebook and stuff like that you know
asking about Tom and concerned about his
dad and stuff like that and you know
giving me words of support having to do
the show by myself because I really
don't and like I said I mentioned this
on the last episode it's a lot harder to
do the show by myself than I thought it
would be because I kind of I admit I
kind of feel like a tool just sitting in
my office talking to myself and actually
I'm I've been putting off doing this
show and stuff like that now originally
as you will see from the title card and
the title of the video of the title of
the video and everything like that I'm
going to be discussing the infamous UK
video nasty phenomenon from the early
1980s now when I thought that Tom was
going to be coming back for this episode
I had actually planned to do another one
of our breakdowns of the episodes of a
haunting because a couple people had
asked when we were gonna do another one
and stuff like that so I had actually
set up everything to do that episode but
then when I found out that he wasn't
going to be back for episode 75 I
decided to push that one back because
you know I like a haunting and stuff
like that but that's kind of like Tom
really loves that show and I always kind
of feel like you know when we do
breakdowns of those episodes he's kind
of got to be here for that because it's
not gonna be any fun without him here
we'll probably be doing another episode
of a haunting when he comes back again
next week and also if you haven't
checked it out already
I posted a another movie review of just
me by myself doing one of my favorite
movies of all time David Lynch's
Mulholland Drive from 2001 so if you
haven't checked that out you might want
to check that out and I'll just do a
quick just do my quick little shoutouts
obviously faceless villain
if you want to check that out I still
have a few audio codes left and thank
you to everybody that has requested them
and that is going to write reviews and
things like that also if you'd like to
support the show go to our patreon page
at 13 o'clock podcast and also we have a
paypal if you would rather not use
patreon I'll probably do this again at
the end of the show so I'm not going to
get into it too much now so as I said on
the main portion of the show today is
gonna be about video nasties which is
actually something that it's a topic
that I've wanted to do probably since
way back in like episode 2 when we
talked about the satanic panic it was
one of the first topics that I wrote
down but we just never really got around
to it I'm kind of more the horror movie
connoisseur much more than Thomas so it
just kept kind of getting put off and
stuff like that but I've been wanting to
do it for a while so I figured you know
since he's not here I decided to do this
one and also I'm going to do before that
is I usually do is our new feature in
2018 I'm going to do a current event so
let's kind of start out with that and
then we will go on from there now for
our current event topic I chose
something that a lot of you probably
write about because this actually made
the rounds of a lot of the mainstream
news channels as kind of like a creepy
news of the weird type story and it's
really pretty horrifying and pretty
horrific and this is the tale of the
Turpin family now David and Louise
Turpin originally from Texas but now
living in California specifically in
Paris California now they have 13
children up until very recently it was
thought that they were quite a happy
family a lot of pictures on their social
media and stuff like that of them and
all their 13 children all the children
dress the same a lot of them had similar
haircuts which you know a little weird
but nothing illegal about that a lot of
pictures of them from Disneyland
evidently they had yearly passes and
would take their 13 children to
Disneyland every year and they would
have these elaborately staged photos
with the Disney characters and all the
kids dressed the same
stuff like that David and Louise Turpin
also recently renewed their wedding vows
with a chapel with Elvis presiding over
and everything like that so there are
also pictures on the internet of them
and their wedding outfits looking all
lovey-dovey with all of their children
around them dressed alike and also with
Elvis and stuff like that now as is
often the case when you have these
pictures of this supposedly ridiculously
happy family and when everyone's making
such a big deal about look how happy we
are look everyone's dressed the same
it's adorable and stuff like that there
was some really really super sketchy
[__] going on behind the scenes the
Turpin family came famously got into the
news because one of their daughters and
their 13 children some of them are
adults I should note there they range in
age from two years old a toddler the
oldest one is 29 but very recently one
of their seventeen year old daughters
took a cell phone out of the house
climbed out of the window and escaped
and went to the police and stuff like
that now she had pictures and all this
other kind of [__] and she tells the
authorities that her parents are keeping
her and all of her siblings captive in
the house they are not allowed to leave
some of them are shackled to the
furniture they have been underfed and
things like that now at this stage they
don't think there was no evidence of any
kind of sexual abuse but for sure the
kids have been starved and things like
that
obviously and happily the parents have
been arrested charged with torture and
child endangerment and we'll probably
and have a court hearing coming up or
has already passed when this comes out
bail has been set at nine million
dollars each now the interesting thing
is that you know when the daughter went
to the authorities and stuff like that
the cops went to the house and they
found 12 of the children in the house
that looked dirty they were malnourished
three or four of them were shackled to
their beds you know there was [__] and
stuff like that evidently now the creepy
thing too is that when the authorities
got to the house the mother Louise
seemed like surprised like what are you
guys doing here almost
she didn't think there was anything
wrong with it which is one of the
weirdest things to me but also when the
authorities found the kids they didn't
realize at first that some of them were
adult because they were so malnourished
and they were so small they thought all
of them were children and they didn't
really find out that some of them were
in their 20s until later on when they
were all taken to various hospitals and
things like that for treatment now it
should be noted that you know whatever
these crazy people these crazy parents
were up to they had apparently never
been reported before there are no
records that they'd ever been reported
to the authorities or Child Protective
Services or anything like that even
though you know after this news story
came out you know some people said oh
you know it was weird that like the kids
would they would all come outside like
to mow the lawn or something like that
then we'd all go back inside they
wouldn't talk to anybody and they said
oh they looked very pale like they you
know never came out to see the Sun or
anything like that and a couple of
neighbors said that when they tried to
speak to the kids you know the kids
would freak out like you know we're not
allowed to talk we're not allowed to
tell you what our names are or anything
like that but like I said it didn't seem
anything egregious enough than anyone
had ever reported them which in a way is
even spookier that they that this had
been going on for such a long time and
no one really knew about it now this
family like many families that have this
this many children were as far as I can
determine were evangelical Christians
had some preachers and their extended
family and the children were all
homeschooled now the interesting thing
too that came to light after the news
story came out was that someone that had
bought the house in Fort Worth Texas
where they used to live before moot
before they moved out to California said
that when they moved in the house they
took pictures of the condition of it and
stuff like that and they said that the
house that how all these windows broken
out and boarded up and stuff like that
and that there was like [__] all over
the walls and the carpet and that a lot
of the backs of the doors had scratches
on them as though somebody had tried to
get out and stuff like that so like I
said this has been going on for a really
long time and it's the creepiest thing
in the world I will put some of the
photos that I found online of this
family I'll put some of them in the
YouTube video some of them it's weird
because some of the photos have the kids
faces
learn out which normally you would do if
they were in my you're a minor but you
know some of them don't have that so I
don't you know I don't know why some of
them are blurred out and some of them
weren't but it's just so creepy they had
all these pictures of them like from
Disneyland and from the wedding and
everything like that and they all looked
smiling and happy and stuff like that
and you have to think like what the hell
did the parents say to those kids like
jeez you know look happy or what we're
not gonna feed you or anything I mean
obviously they weren't feeding them
anyway but anyways just a horrible
horrible story and like I said it made
the rounds I found articles about on CNN
I found out everywhere so it was kind of
a big deal so you know that's kind of
our current event for the day kind of
yucky but I thought it kind of went with
the whole topic of today's show which is
kind of ostensibly about Family Values
in an in a weird way so I guess it kind
of fits in so now that we've kind of
covered that news story let's get on to
the main meat of the episode which is
the UK video nasty controversy now as I
said this is a topic I've been wanting
to do for quite a long time probably
ever since we did the show about the
satanic panic because this is kind of a
similar thing full disclosure I do not
live in the UK I used to go back and
forth there quite a bit from the mid 90s
to about the late 2000s because I used
to be married to a British person so we
would go back and forth to visit his
family usually once a year so I've been
there a lot and also I should say that
my ex-husband was super into you know
exploitation films and old horror films
and stuff like that particularly the
Italian horror movies and stuff like
that so he knew a great deal and you
know he grew up in Britain at around the
time that the whole video nasty panic
was going on and he had several books
about the topic which I read over the
years and things like that so I do kind
of have some kind of passing knowledge
of it less so about what happens
subsequently so for that information I'm
actually mostly sourcing from a site UK
horror site called realm of horror which
has a list of all the video nasties and
what happened to them subsequently how
they were released and things like that
now it might be hard for people in the
u.s. to fathom how big a deal this kind
of was in the UK in the early
ATS because we didn't really have an
equivalent at least not in regards to
movies or home video or anything like
that probably the closest equivalent
that happened in the United States would
be the whole parents music Resource
Center the PMRC and everything like that
that we're trying to label you know
music records and things like that like
you know the whole furor over to Live
Crew and you know there are obscene
lyrics and stuff of that things of that
nature so that's probably kind of a
similar thing I don't feel like I mean I
do remember that era but I don't
remember it being quite as big a deal as
it seemed to be in the UK with the video
nasties so what I wanted to kind of do
is sort of give like kind of a rundown
of how the whole thing took place and
[__] like that and then I kind of want
to maybe get into after the break some
of the movies you know there were on the
infamous video nasties list why they
were on there you know the difference
between ones that were on there ones
that were left off you know the whole
kind of arbitrary nature of it maybe go
off on some other kind of tangents about
it and stuff like that so even though I
guess you know the main part of the
whole video nasty panic didn't really
come about until you know the early to
mid 80s there were actually kind of
precursors of it starting and you know
that maybe about the mid 70s now where a
lot of the controversy arose now in
Britain they'd always had the BBFC
British Board of Film censors that type
of thing
you know equivalent to the American MPAA
who would watch the movie screen the
movies and who would rate them you know
for particular ages and things like that
now in the u.s. sometimes I don't know
if it's quite as publicized over here
sometimes movies are cut in the u.s.
also but usually they're cut to get a
particular rating like you know the MPA
will come to a filmmaker and we'll say
you know this is going to get an X
rating or you know the more recent nc-17
rating if you don't cut you know XY and
Z scenes out of it to get an R and most
filmmakers will do that because if a
film has an nc-17 rating a lot of
theaters won't show it and things like
that so well you know they they at least
one an R rating so sometimes they will
cut things out because of that so it
seems like prior to Home Video becoming
a thing there wasn't really a huge deal
about movies that showed in the theatres
in the UK and ironically a lot of the
movies that would cause so much
controversy later on when they came out
on home video were actually passed with
no cuts or with minimal cuts to show in
the theaters now the argument that they
made about that was because well when
you go to a movie theater you know the
movie has a rating and you know no one
of that age theoretically is supposed to
be under there seeing that movie anyway
so it's not really that big a deal
now it should be noted there was no law
really I mean there was a lot about
movies there was an obscenity law and
stuff like that the obscenity law came
from 1959 it was updated again in 1977
but it was mostly that was mostly having
to do with porn films now one of the
first movies to kind of catch the
attention of the censors and and kind of
maybe priests aged a lot of the video
nasty phenomenon later on was the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre which came out in the
early 70s of 1974 now this movie was
submitted for certification you know or
for rating as they would say in the u.s.
to the BBFC now the guy who was in
charge of the BBFC at the time thought
the movie was very well made but refused
it a certificate because he thought that
it was too violent for an 18 rating but
didn't see where it could be cut to
bring it into to bring it to the
standard of an 18 movie just because the
movie is based so much around the whole
atmosphere the whole premise of the
movie really is what makes it horrific
because it's not just a case of oh let's
cut out this gore scene and stuff like
that because the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
doesn't despite its title and its
reputation is actually really not all
that gory so there's really nothing you
can cut out so the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre was actually denied a
certificate and actually didn't show in
the UK for quite a for quite a while if
if I'm reading it correctly so you know
there was like I said kind of a
precursor to the sort of later
this whole thing about what can we show
what can be cut out and things of that
nature but then along came the late 70s
and the home video boom now I've talked
before on the show I believe it was on
our movie review of time after time and
I've talked about this on my blog too
that I kind of count myself lucky that I
kind of came of age like right around
the time when the home video boom was
you know just getting really big and and
things like that and it might be hard
for younger people to understand that
there was a time and I remember this
time like when I was a little kid that
you couldn't just see whatever movie you
wanted to see whenever you wanted to I
mean a movie would come out in the
theatres if you didn't see it in the
theater then you would prop you would
have to wait until it came out on TV and
sometimes that would be years and years
you know you couldn't just let go rent
it you couldn't just stream it like you
can now it's like you know if you didn't
see it you were kind of out of luck so
in the late 70s in the US and also in
the UK people begin to buy video
recorders and begin to be interested in
renting movies to watch at home now
there wasn't a lot of stuff to choose
from back then because major film
studios in the US and the UK were
actually kind of reluctant to jump on
board with this whole home video thing
because they were worried about piracy
and things like that which you know
still nowadays and that that cats way
out of the bag so I don't think they see
it's just kind of quaint like to think
that they were worried about it back
then but you know people are gonna copy
the videotapes and you know give them to
their friends and stuff like that people
aren't gonna pay it's the same you know
tale is all this time so a lot of the
major studios wouldn't release their big
movies on home video for a really really
long time so since people had spent [__]
tons of money on Betamax ha's and later
VCRs they obviously wanted some stuff to
watch on them so there was kind of a gap
in the market now since the law for the
cinematic showing of movies had not
taken into account the home video boom
there was actually no law regulating any
movies that came out on home video so
pretty much for a while
anything went
so in this kind of gap caused by the law
and by the major studios not wanting to
release their big-ticket movies on home
video for fear of piracy then all of
these kind of little fly-by-night
distribution companies popped up and
their main meat and potatoes since they
couldn't get any main any major
Hollywood productions or any large
productions or anything like that was to
import cheap shitty exploitation movies
from other countries you know in the UK
they imported a lot of American slasher
movies a lot of infamous Italian films
which are super gory and they would put
those out and for a while they were not
regulated and what they would call that
now was pre cert as in pre certification
because there was no requirement for
home video you didn't have to give them
to the BBFC to be cut or to be rated or
anything like that you could just it was
kind of like a Wild West kind of thing
you could just put out whatever now
everything went along like that for a
little while people were just renting
slasher movies and Italian zombie movies
and porn and stuff like that from these
just little video mom-and-pop video
shops that had popped up all over
England and this went on for a little
while but then the problem arose and
it's actually kind of funny how this
came about the problem arose from mainly
from two movies but actually maybe three
movies now
go video who was one of the independent
distributors they had imported a little
movie called Cannibal Holocaust from
Italy now to kind of get some publicity
for this movie they took a copy of their
of their movie and they sent an
anonymous letter to Mary Whitehouse
who was then the head of the National
viewers and listeners Association very
religious woman very one of those very
super Christian morally upright busybody
type old ladies so they sent a letter
purportedly complaining about this filth
and everything like that to Mary
Whitehouse along with the copy of the
movie now this was actually meant to
stir up outrage stir up publicity and
stuff like that for their movie you know
just just like you would do
you know it's a small business and
they're trying to get attention somehow
and this horribly horribly backfired on
them because that action was one of the
things that brought this unregulated
video market to the attention of a lot
of the moral watchdogs of the day and
that's kind of what ended up
spearheading the entire video nasty
witch-hunt of moral panic or whatever
you want to call it now another thing
too that came about was the American
film the driller killer by Abel Ferrara
had actually their distributor had
actually put out like full-page ads in
various video magazines and newspapers
and stuff like that advertising the
movie and they perhaps unwisely for the
advertisement used a still from the
movie which showed a guy like a pretty
graphic shot of a guy getting a drill
right into his forehead and this was
another thing that kind of spearheaded
the whole thing and there was also
another movie that kind of added to it
to these kind of three films were sort
of the thing that kind of kicked off the
the major part of the panic was SS
experiment camp one of the many Nazis
ploy tation movies which would turn up
on the list much later on when attention
was drawn to this movie you know a lot
of the people of the BBFC and stuff like
that are like oh my god we can't have
movies of Nazi atrocities and stuff like
that and all this kind of sexual
violence having to do with Nazis and
they just didn't really take didn't
really take too kindly to it so it was
probably a combination of those three
things that that sort of kicked off the
whole brouhaha about the unregulated
video market and all of these imported
horror films mainly horror films that
some people believed were you know
responsible for corrupting Britain's
youth now one of the main players in
this was the infamous Daily Mail which
it may still be when I was over there it
was either called the daily fail or the
daily Heil as in Heil Hitler
an infamous kind of right right-wing
tabloid that pretty much once that once
the
moral panic had started they ran a story
pretty much every day about how this or
that movie had caused this or that crime
most of it was false or completely
exaggerated but they kind of took it
upon themselves to quote-unquote ban the
sadist videos and that was one of their
big flagship Crusades in the early to
mid 80s so Mary Whitehouse the recipient
of the copy of Cannibal Holocaust she
took it upon herself to start writing
letter after letter after letter you
know talking about these horrible
degenerate movies and they're causing
all kinds of problems and all this other
kind of stuff and they should be banned
and blah-dee-blah she even wrote letters
to the BBC and things like that you know
about some of the stuff they were
showing and things of that nature she
basically just went off on a tear so
what ended up happening since there was
no law specifically regulating home
video movies on home video so what they
decided to do they said well you know
until we can get something passed we
will just say that these movies fall
afoul of the obscene publications Act
and you know which gives police the
authority to go in and seize copies of
the movie now this was all well and good
and you know not from my point of view
obviously but from their point of view
but the problem was that a lot of times
I mean there were so many of these
videos you know nobody had time to watch
them all they were just flooding the
country from all over the place and so
at first there was really no you know it
was very it was a very arbitrary
distinction like which ones could be
seized and which ones couldn't you know
very famously one raid I believe it was
in Manchester and they can't win in a
video store and seized a bunch of titles
that they thought were you know ran
afoul of the video obscenities Act but
one of them was the best little
whorehouse in Texas which is a comedy
it's a musical comedy with Dolly Parton
and so that was seized very famously
just and things like that so it was
getting to a point where police were
like okay well if you want us to seize
the videos fine but we don't have any
idea which ones to take it's like you
know we haven't seen them we don't know
what's in them which ones are which ones
it
just the cover it's just the name we
don't know so eventually there had to be
a list produced so the police would know
which which titles were quote-unquote
illegal or you know could be taken off
of shelves and which ones could be left
there now that kind of opened up a whole
other can of worms because yes they did
finally they did finalized a list
problem was the list was pretty much
just as arbitrary as not even having a
list would have been because I mean
there was stuff on the list that is just
who knew why it was on there it was just
put on there because it had you know a
lurid sounding title or a lurid looking
cover you know and really the film
wasn't that gory or wasn't that bad
and you know meanwhile there were a lot
of other movies that were arguably worse
than some of the ones on the list that
were for some reason not it did not come
to the attention of the censors and you
know passed by completely unremarked and
I'm gonna get into that a little bit
after the break but it's just the whole
I don't know just the whole arbitrary
nature of this is very funny to me and
that's why I kind of wanted to go into
some of the movies that were on the list
some of the ones that were left off you
know why some of the ones that were on
there we're on there and you know things
of that nature because that's kind of
stuff I find fascinating so since we're
getting about to the halfway point I'm
gonna take a break right here and when
we come back I'm going to discuss some
of the individual films that were on the
list and why they were on there and just
some other kind of little trivia about
them and stuff like that cuz I love this
kind of [__] I love horror movies I love
exploitation movies of all kinds and I
kind of want to get a little bit into
censorship and whether you know whether
or not I feel like this has ever
justified or anything like that so we
will talk all about all that when I come
back and we are gonna take a break and
we will be back in just a couple minutes
[Music]
okay we're back talking about the video
nasties so once a list was produced of
all the prosecutable titles on video
subsequently now this went on for a
couple of years subsequently 1984 a
Conservative member of parliament named
Graham bright actually submitted a bill
that was going to be called the video
recordings Act 1984 which made it an
offence for a video movie to be sold or
rented to the public if it had not been
run through the BBFC for rating or for
cuts or whatever so now let's talk about
the infamous video nasties list now this
list and you will find many copies of it
around the internet consisted of 72
films that were on the BB F C's [__]
list at one time or another as movies
that could be prosecuted if they were
found on the shelves of rental stores
and stuff like that like you you know
they were allowed to be seized if they
were seen now it should be noted that up
these 72 films only 39 of them were ever
successfully prosecuted some of them
were seized some of them were later
dropped from the list some of them they
attempted to prosecute them but failed
so you know they're really only 39 of
them that were considered you know the
worst of the worst and even then like I
said it's very it's a very arbitrary
distinction but only 39 were ever
successfully prosecuted there was also a
kind of supplementary list ones that
could be seized that were kind of in a
limbo you could seize them and then try
to prosecute them and things like that
so there were a bunch more movies on
that list and then there were some other
ones that were kind of you know in a
gray area and I'm kind of gonna go into
that as well now it should be noted and
you know even though this happened later
on I think I'll mention it now even
though a lot of these movies were banned
outright or had huge amounts of cuts or
you know were seized and people were
even prosecuted in in a few instances
for having them in their stores or
selling them or renting them or whatever
after James Furman who was head of the
BBFC during most of the video nasty
panic
after he retired in 1999 the standards
for censorship and stuff like that were
relaxed massively and most of the movies
that were on the video nasties list back
in the day have since been released
uncut in the UK and even ones that still
had cuts it seems to me and maybe some
of our British listeners can specify
this a little bit more but it seems to
me from what I've read that really the
only thing that still gets cut nowadays
is actual real Cruelty to Animals has
turned up in a lot of the cannibal
movies most famously Cannibal Holocaust
and sexual violence rape scenes and
things like that are still kind of an
iffy proposition those seem like the
only things that get cut out of movies
nowadays but like I said the majority of
the movies that were once on the video
nasties list have since been released in
the UK completely uncut some of them
have been shown at film festivals and
things like that so like I said it's
been a massive relaxation and honestly
you know with the advent of the internet
and stuff like that censorship is kind
of like closing the barn door after the
horses have got out it's like you know
there's really no way I mean if you want
to see a movie in its uncut version you
know there's an uncut version in the
world somewhere - on a torrent site or
you can order them from overseas because
even ones that have cuts in them in the
UK a lot of times the US version or the
version made for mainland Europe don't
have any cuts so you can get them from
there too so it's it's almost like I
think the BBFC aside from realizing that
they have may have been a little
overzealous back in the 80s with some of
the movies especially when you see some
of them now they're just ridiculous like
why would anybody cut that it's not that
bad or anything like that but I think
they also realized that there really was
no point I mean you know like I said if
you wanted to see these movies there's
you can easily see pretty much any of
them that you want to nowadays now one
of the most interesting things to me
about this list like I said is the very
arbitrary nature of it now let's talk
about a movie called axe which is also
known as California axe murderers
sometimes known as Lesa Lesa not a
terribly gory movie it was originally
released
in the cinema in movie theaters in UK in
the UK with about three minutes of cuts
and was later passed uncut in 2006 but
the weird thing about this movie one
other than the fact that it's like
hardly gory at all and there's like why
would you even cut it but the weird
thing is that there was another movie by
the same director that was called date
with the kidnapper that was very similar
a similar amount of gore similar kind of
vibe similar kind of thing that did not
turn up on the list and I'm going to
mention that more than once because that
to me just seems very strange it's even
why this movie was put on the list and
not this other one you know because
sometimes the ones that turned up on the
list
were far less gory far less upsetting
than some of the ones that never even
get mentioned and I just find that
really interesting and probably the most
egregious example of that is ours of
some of the movies of Lucci of full
Chino I'm a big full chief fan I like
all his gore movies I've even liked a
lot of his other because he made of [__]
ton of other kind of movies too
I think I talked a little bit about him
on our show about giallo movies now he
had three movies on the video nasties
list these being the beyond zombie also
known as zombie flesh eaters I think
it's more commonly known as Amba flesh
eaters in the UK here it's just known as
simply zombie and also housed by the
cemetery now I'm really into all three
of those movies I think they're great
movies they're classic zombie movies but
the interesting thing to me is that even
though these three movies were on the
[__] list the video nasties list
interestingly city of the Living Dead
was not put on the list no but it was
seized a couple of times but it was
never put on the list it was never
official that it could be seized or
anything like that
even though city of the Living Dead has
a scene of a woman barfing up her own
intestines which like I said is a lot
worse than some of this stuff that they
cut out I'm other ones and stuff like
that so I just find that really
interesting that of all this devil like
he's three movies on the list and City
the Living Dead it didn't even turn up
on there which I thought was very weird
and I should be noted it should be noted
too I'd like also like to mention too
that even
I mean there are some good movies that
turned up on this list most of the
movies on here are really not good
they're just like shitty cheap schlocky
exploitation movies which you know I dig
those and stuff like that but I feel
like the bigger deal that was made out
made of them because they ended up on
the video nasties list really made
people remember them but obviously way
more than the quality of the movie did
because frankly if a lot of these movies
had not turned up on the video nasties
list everyone was just forgotten about
them they wouldn't have cared about
these movies because most of them were
pretty bad I mean most Ammar pretty
cheap
some of them laughably cheap so you know
as in the case of any kind of moral
panic like this the more somebody makes
a big deal about you shouldn't see this
it's filth it's this and that that's
gonna make people want to see it more
and I think that's definitely something
that happened during the video nasties
furor and I think a lot of horror fans
people that were into exploitation
movies were kind of happy when the whole
the official list of the 72 video
nasties came out who said that how
here's a recommendation list now I know
what movies to look for and stuff like
that and it just ended up making these
movies a lot better known a lot more
infamous and notorious than they
probably would have been and like I said
I think that's something else that
people that are young now probably
wouldn't understand but you know back in
the old days when it was a lot harder to
get your hands on you know foreign
movies like on VHS and stuff like that
there was kind of a thrill of the
forbidden and I think the video nasty
thing like played right into that
because you know already as soon as as
soon as like all these like Yuri
conservative like evangelical Christian
kind of people are like flipping out
about these particular movies it's kind
of like what happened in the satanic
panic everybody talking about dungeons
of dragons and stuff like that and you
know death metal records and everything
it just made people want them more
especially teenagers because you know
adults you know tell them not to do
something and that's obviously
automatically what they want to do so so
obviously being on the video nasties
list helped out a lot of these movies
and made them a lot more infamous even
though a lot of them are pretty shitty I
haven't seen them all I've seen a lot of
them but some of them are just just
terrible terrible movies and not to do
with an ego or anything like that just
very cheaply made the act
shitty and stuff like that but like I
said there were some good ones on the
list as well now some of the good ones
that turned up on the list that I always
said I wanted to mention famously Mario
Baba's Bay of blood sometimes known as
twitch of the death nerve sometimes
known as bloodbath this is actually a
notable film because it's and I talked
about it a little bit our jello show as
well because it's kind of like the first
slasher film really it's um you know I
know people can arguable psycho is maybe
the first slasher film Bay of blood is
actually the first thing that you would
recognize as a slasher who's very
slasher esque
and actually Friday the 13th part two
ripped off two scenes from this pretty
much directly so that was also on the
list blood feast considered probably the
first splatter flick from 1963 Herschell
Gordon Lewis you know this is obviously
a terrible now I love HG Lewis movies
although 2,000 maniacs is probably my
favorite but blood feast is pretty good
too in a so bad it's good kind of way
and you have to think that you know even
though the special effects are laughable
now I mean obviously the blood is just
temper of paint and you know it's just
you know it's laughably bad but I mean
this was very very ahead of its time
very subversive for 1963 I mean nobody
had seen a quote-unquote splatter flick
and this is kind of the first one so it
was also on the list now I also want to
mention and I talked about this a little
bit before you know a lot of a cannibal
movies that came out a lot of them were
Italian a couple of them were Spanish
now these ones were kind of a special
case because a lot of the cannibal
movies not all of them but a lot of them
it came out specifically Cannibal
Holocaust cannibal apocalypse and stuff
like that the reason most of the reason
they ran into trouble and a reason why a
lot of them are still they're not banned
anymore I don't think one or two of them
might be but why a lot of them have been
released still with cuts is because they
have actual animal cruelty in them like
I said Cannibal Holocaust famously has
people killing a turtle and you know it
was staged for the movie and that's kind
of shitty I can understand why they
would take something like that out
although you know I would argue that you
know they made the movie a long time ago
back in the 70s
like you you know you can't have those
animals come back and not be dead
anymore so it really seems kind of
pointless to cut it but I can see to
that if you don't really want to see
real actual cruelty to animals then you
know maybe you would prefer to see the
cut-up version of that the interesting
thing about Cannibal Holocaust though is
that it was actually it was rumored to
be and actually the the filmmakers were
actually dry either dragged into court
or threatened to drag into court because
some people thought was a snuff movie
and I'm gonna talk about that a little
bit later on it's actually not all the
peoples that are inert and are fine the
actors showed up in court it's totally
fine but the animals that were in it not
so fine so you know I can see why you
might not want to watch that some other
decent ones that appeared on the list
Andy Warhol's flesh for Frankenstein
which is actually very good movies very
campy very fun you know care is in it
interestingly even though flesh for
Frankenstein was on the nasties list
his other boobie Andy Warhol's other
produced movie a blood for Dracula was
not on the list even though blood for
Dracula is a lot gory er than flesh for
Frankenstein at least from my point of
view another movie that got put on there
probably erroneously was the movie
funhouse made by tobe Hooper who
obviously also made the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre now this movie I don't think
this was supposed to be on there because
it's you know it's a standard slasher
it's not terribly gory especially not as
gory as some of the ones that weren't
even on the list but it is widely
believed that tobe Hooper's funhouse was
mistakenly put on the list the BBFC were
actually thinking of a movie called The
Last House on dead-end street
whose alternate title was the funhouse
and that one was a lot gory Urso that's
probably the one they were targeting and
they accidentally got tobe Hooper's
funhouse which is actually a pretty
decent slasher movie stars the chick
that played Stasi and Amadeus little fun
fact for you they're now two of the most
infamous movies that were on the list
and are actually two movies that I
actually really liked were very famous
rape revenge movies there were a lot of
those in the 70s I Spit on Your Grave
and Last House on the Left Wes Craven's
very famous movie now these two movies
like I said that seems to be and that
seems to be the only remaining one of
the only remaining things that will get
your movie cut in the UK nowadays is
sexual violence rape scenes stuff like
that now it should be noted I Spit on
Your Grave
starring Camille Keaton is a movie that
I actually really like I can understand
if you don't like it it's pretty hard to
watch the rape scenes in it are
particularly grueling but I wrote
actually a big long thing about it on my
blog where I kind of argued that if
you're gonna show a rape in a movie I
actually think it's more socially
responsible to show it like this to show
it realistically and to show it really
sick and horrible it should be
uncomfortable to watch because I mean
that's what it's like in real life so I
don't really have a problem with showing
that in a movie however it should be
noted I Spit on Your Grave is one of the
few movies that was on the video nasty
list originally that is still available
in the UK only as a cut version now
they've they've cut less out as the
years went on but last I heard the
version that's available in the UK still
has two minutes and 54 seconds cut out
of it mostly cut out of the rape scenes
because the rape scenes in this are very
long that they do go on a very long time
and they're very upsetting to watch but
you know obviously you can get an uncut
version in the US and in other parts of
Europe
same thing with Last House on the Left I
think Last House on the Left has since
been released uncut and the interesting
thing about that too is that there's
another movie and I think it's called
house on the edge of the park which was
also in the video nasty list and is very
similar to last house in the list left
it also stars David Hess who was in last
house and the left as crude but house on
the edge of the park was actually much
worse but I think I think as far as I
can tell they're both available uncut
now I also wanted as far as the whole
arbitrary nature goes I also wanted to
mention Dario Argento who obviously a
big fan of to now a couple of his movies
turned up on the list these would be
Inferno and tenebrae Tenebrae only on
there generally just because of the
scene at the end where that woman gets
her arm cut off and sprays blood all
over the kitchen or whatever but the
interesting thing to me is that even
though Inferno and Tenebrae were both on
the
Suspiria was not even that the gore I
mean from my point of view the gore is
comparable in all three of those movies
so like I said I don't know why Inferno
and Tenebrae were targeted when Suspiria
was not because you know that's all and
like I said again you know the movie
review that's coming out this week will
probably be Suspiria so Dario Argento
fans represent and then there are also
movies on there that I don't really have
any idea why they were on there like
visiting hours which actually had some
pretty big stars in it Michael Ironside
was in it William Shatner was in it and
not much gore and stuff like that but
for some reason that ended up on the
list as well now aside from the list of
the 72 main movies that are on the list
the 39 that were prosecuted and stuff
like that there was also another list
called section 3 video nasties and these
ones the law said they couldn't be
prosecuted for obscenity but they could
still be seized under a less obscene
charge you know the same kind of thing
on here there was movies like Martin
marca the devil has some more cannibal
movies and stuff like that and that was
another thing too that I wanted to
mention that a lot of the movies that
turned up on the infamous 72 video
nasties list we're really only put on
there because of their cover art or
their titles like you know Cannibal
Holocaust cannibal apocalypse okay those
were very gory that animal cruelty and
them and stuff like that but then you
get another movie like the cannibal man
from Spain which didn't have any gore in
it at all really except for a short
thing at the beginning but was probably
only put on the list because of its name
I don't really think anybody had sat and
watched it or anything like that they
just put on the list because it had
cannibal in the name and there were some
other cannibal ones that turned up on
the section 3 one as well you know a lot
of Dawn of the Dead was on the was on
the section 3 list as was a deep red
another Dario Argento movie also called
per Fonda raw so you know none of the
Living Dead things like that so like I
said it's just just kind of a ridiculous
sort of thing now there were also some
movies that were we're also banned by
the BBF BBFC but we're not considered
video nasties for whatever reason even
though
some of them were horror movies one of
these was maniac which actually when
they submit which they wouldn't even let
them show it in the cinema or in movie
theaters it was it was denied a
certification so since it was denied
certification for cinema than they're
working to show they weren't gonna allow
it to be released on home video either
now it was eventually released in the UK
but it still had about a minute of cuts
in it I remember seeing that movie I
don't the only part I really remember
being bad was that guy getting scalped
and it wasn't really that big a deal so
I don't I don't know if that was the
only if that was the scene they took out
or whether New York Ripper similar kind
of thing that was also released in 2002
but has had 29 seconds cut out another
interesting one was straw dogs Sam
Peckinpah's movie now this one actually
played in the theaters uncut when it
first come came out but right around the
whole video nasties pure it was pulled
but it wasn't officially put on the list
and then it was re-released in theaters
in the 90s but then when they tried to
submit it for video release it kept
getting denied until 2002 like I said
after the after the main guy had left
that you know the main guy that was
causing all the problems he had left and
the standards were relaxed so it was
finally released in 2002 there were
other ones that were seized over the
time basket case for example McCobb city
of the Living Dead which I mentioned
before let you full G movie and stuff
like that but we're never really
prosecuted now an interesting thing too
is that there were some movies that and
and I actually I had some British pen
pals back in the day and one of the most
infamous movies that they'd wanted to
see but never had been able to was
Stanley Kubrick's A Clockwork Orange
now even though and actually even some
of my friends in Britain thought this
they actually thought that the BBFC had
banned a Clockwork Orange and that was
actually not the case
it wasn't technically banned it was just
because Stanley Kubrick would not allow
the film to be seen there because
evidently he would tried to show it he
had gotten death threats and he was
afraid that it would be cut and things
like that so he pretty much withdrew it
from consideration it was
just not even gonna show it here because
it's too much of a pain so it wasn't the
BBFC bandit he just didn't want it shown
there because of the atmosphere around
the censorship and everything like that
so that was actually a movie that a lot
of my British friends wanted to see and
they had never been able to see it which
at the time you know it's one of my
favorite movies so I thought it was very
odd that they weren't able to see it
especially since its kind of you know
it's set in Britain and stuff like that
but the film was eventually released fun
cut right around 2000 after Stanley
Kubrick died now I also want to mention
something too about the main part of
this like I said went probably from the
early 80s to the mid to late 80s but it
kind of continued into the 90s a little
bit now child's play three was one of
the ones that got attention later on
because the media tried to establish a
link between the movie child's play
three and the infamous murder of Jamie
Bulger now this murder famously happened
in 1993 and the little boy was in a
shopping mall with his mom and kind of
wandered off or his mom lost track of
him or whatever and these two other
little boys lured him out of the mall
and actually ended up beating the little
boy to death and leaving him on a train
tracks leaving him on the train tracks
where his body was subsequently cut in
half now the media made much of the fact
that these two little boys that had done
this that they had watched child's play
three and that they had got the idea
from there and everything like that now
there's actually no proof that they'd
actually even watched that movie I
believe one of their parents had rented
it or something like that but they you
know there was no proof that the kids
had seen it or anything like that
but in any case the media kind of
started this big thing about child's
play three and it was you know causing
our children to kill other children and
oh my goodness and all this other kind
of [__] so the movie was effectively
vilified and there was another murder
that went on around the same time which
was the murder of suzanne capper who was
a young girl who was kidnapped and
tortured and was
eventually set on fire and that kind of
happened around the same time so child's
play three kind of got associated with
that as well video nasties also kind of
blamed a little bit in the case of the
hunger Hunger food massacre where a guy
shot sixteen Shawn killed 16 people so
you know the argument here really is you
know how much do these movies really
affect people's behavior I tend to think
yes there have been studies that show
that children that watch violent things
you know tend to act more aggressively
but you know there's been a lot of
criticism of some of those studies as
well like they weren't like they weren't
done personally well you know there were
no controls or whatever I can really
only speak for my own personal
experience here I've been watching
horror movies you know ever since I was
a little kid I was always really into
scary movies and horror and stuff like
that
my mom would let me watch that was good
I mean when I was a kid I never had a
problem distinguishing between real life
and what was in a movie I mean horror
movies did some horror movies did scare
me when I was a little kid but I never
thought that they were real so you know
I don't have any children now so I can't
really say but on the whole I kind of
feel like as long as everyone in the
movie is like obviously I don't agree
that you should be able to show snuff
films or child porn or anything like
that because you know there's a consent
issue and stuff like that but generally
as far as horror movies go it's you know
it's all fake you know I'm not gonna get
into the whole morality of you know if
people are messed up if they watch this
instantly because I love this [__] and
I'm you know normal and well-adjusted
this farce I can tell and stuff so this
kind of stuff doesn't really bother me
they're just fun they're entertainment
and honestly I you know there's still a
distinction to be made I don't
particularly like to watch you know real
things you know people really getting
executed or people I don't get any
happiness out of that and I would rather
not watch them but horror movies like I
said they're just fun they're fake it's
just another you know a lot a lot of
people have compared them to a roller
coaster you know it's like an endurance
test something like that you know and I
would agree with that and honestly I
think too that people who are really
into horror movies you know you have
that outlet you're
violence usually but it's fake it's
stylized violence and stuff like that in
a way I think it kind of would make you
less likely to be into violence in real
life and you know like I said I don't
know how much scientific backing there
is I do but that's generally been my
personal experience so you know I don't
want to watch snuff movies or anything
like that which I'm sure probably
floating around the internet somewhere
nowadays but you know I I don't really
have a problem with horror movies in
general I don't really have a problem
with kids of a certain age watching them
because I did and you know I didn't
develop any psychological problems or
anything as a result of it because I
knew they were fake and honestly - I
think it's you know it's up to the
parents really so I really don't think
it's it's the purview of you know the
BBFC or anyone like that to cut things
out of films because they think that it
will make people degenerate or that kids
might see it or something like that I
mean you know kids might do a lot of
things so in that way obviously I think
the whole video nasty if you're just
like the whole satanic panic over here
the thing over here overreach -
egregious and stuff like that it's just
it's entertainment they're movies
they're not real so that's kind of how I
feel about that and also like I said
that it's the whole standardization of
it was just so arbitrary and some movies
are on the list and some word I mean
some pass with no cuts some had a ton of
cuts even though they were very similar
so you know there's really no way of
regulating this kind of thing
effectively and especially not nowadays
now we have the internet you can see
pretty much anything you want to see
anytime you want to see it so really I
don't think there's any way that this
can be regulated or broader control in
any way whatsoever and I don't really
think we should even try because like I
said it's it's fake so I guess that will
kind of do it for this episode hope you
guys enjoyed this kind of rambling
discussion of horror movies because you
know like I said this is something that
I decided to do since Tom wasn't here
and I had to do another one by myself
because you know I'm kind of the horror
movie person and he's not as into them
as I am and I've seen a lot of like I
said I've seen a lot of the ones on the
nasties list so I thought it was
something that I could do without too
much trouble
so as I said there will be one more
movie review that's
just gonna be me on my own it will
probably be Suspiria and that will
probably be up on Friday and then after
that starting with episode 76 which like
I said will probably be another episode
of a haunting we'll see how that goes
when he gets back
should have Tom on the back because he's
coming back on January 26th other than
that please remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe on all your
social media and if you would like to
support the show please go to our
patreon page which is wwp tree on Comm
slash 13 o'clock podcast and give it
monthly donation or if you would rather
not use patreon then you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
WordPress com and there is a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account to which you
may make a one-time or several time
donation whatever you'd like to do we
appreciate any support also if you're
into true-crime please check out my book
the faceless villain which is out in
print ebook and audiobook formats I
still have a few codes left for free
audiobooks if you would like one of
those how to promise to write a review
though it doesn't have to be long but
just contact me through the show or
anything like that on our Facebook page
and I will make sure you get a code I
still have a few left and thanks to
everyone that has written reviews so far
also check out zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock we have some t-shirt designs and
stuff like that I'm eventually gonna put
some more up I believe there's six or
seven up right now but I put some more
up as the months go by whenever I have
time also don't forget to check out my
last movie review which was also just me
which is David Lynch's Mulholland Drive
one of my favorite movies ever so go
check that out if you haven't already
and that will do it for episode 75 about
video nasties see you next time bye
[Music]
you